so my last video on
the uh the question of christianity not
being revolutionary got quite a bit of
reaction
a lot of people uh a lot of
long comments people who uh didn't
totally agree with what i was saying um
maybe i didn't totally formulate it
right
in using the word revolutionary some
people
um maybe didn't unders i tried to
explain what i meant by revolutionary
which is basically the idea of
lower aspects of reality trying to take
uh from above
um but nonetheless it got quite a bit of
reaction even some i even
saw a reaction video which was very very
critical of me
in manners which were a little bit
excessive more than a little bit let's
say
excessive in the sense that the person
didn't seem to really engage with my
argument but
rather engaged uh with his imagination
about what i was saying and
what i was implying so you know for
anybody who's been following my work for
quite a while
you know that i don't think that i'm not
a
i do believe in the problem of tyranny i
do believe that uh you know
in my video about the number of the
beast all this types of symbolism of the
the difficulty of hyper masculinity in
the sense of the desire
to to uh impose order too much the tower
of babel i talk quite a bit about the
the problem of authority and so
but i thought it made me think that
maybe it'd be a good idea to look at the
way in which christ himself
criticizes the people that are in power
the people that have authority
and how the way that he criticizes them
is
actually another version of how christ
fills the hierarchy
and how christ is there to manifest the
fullness of the entire
you know spread of being um and also
show us the reason for why sometimes it
is
laid out in a hierarchy and so uh so
anyways we'll look at that
and i think it'll be interesting
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so the interesting thing is that christ
like many prophets
is you know like some of the prophets in
the old testament is constantly
criticizing those
in authority he actually doesn't
criticize
the worldly authorities there is nowhere
in scripture
where he criticizes the romans but he
does criticize
both the spiritual authority and he also
criticizes
uh rich people people who have a lot and
people who
are lenders or that you know that lend
money to to others or that
um incur debts from other people and so
he definitely criticizes those people
and so
i thought it would be a good idea to
look at that and why it is and how it is
that he criticizes that you know not
just in terms of
not in terms of sentimentalism and just
kind of get offended and you know this
the type of sentimentalism and easy
thinking that people get into
just being offended at structures um
christ has a lot of things which are so
offensive that was one of the reason for
my last video
was actually to to maybe not flinch
on how offensive some of the things
christ says
and in the past maybe people would have
been more offended by the times in which
he criticizes the powerful and the rich
but today people get more offended at
the times where he shows
the way in which authority comes down
and the way in which authority can
sometimes
be very severe if the bottom of the
hierarchy
doesn't participate in the whole process
but
it's very fine to look at the other side
as well that's what we're going to do so
christ the reason why the best way to
understand
most of the criticism that christ has
they're basically two
uh types of criticism and both of those
criticisms
are showing how those that are
above in any hierarchy whether it's a
hierarchy of spiritual authority whether
it's a hierarchy of power
in the terms of material power
the criticism that he poses is anything
that
stops the flow of things moving from
above down below or another way to see
it
is he criticizes any time in which
the the that which is above and that
which is below doesn't connect together
and so one of the biggest criticisms
that um
christ has is hypocrisy and we have to
understand how hypocrisy
is exactly that hypocrisy is a
separation of heaven and earth
it means that you hold ideals and then
you don't embody those ideals in the
world
and so the the biggest criticism that
of course christ has of the pharisees
is that they are hypocrites that they
hold these very very high ideals about
the law about
how to practice spiritual life and then
they do not
embody those ideals in the world and so
you can see that even in the text in
matthew where christ
someone mentioned that in the comments
which is that christ first says to the
people
follow the pharisees because they are
the illegitimate authority they are
sitting in the seat of moses there was a
tradition according to which there was
an
there was a there was both a written
tradition and there was like an oral
authority so there was a
a uh a priestly authority which came
down from uh
from uh aaron and you can see that in
the hierarchy of the priest that would
have served in the temple but that there
was also
with something you could call like the
uh a prophetic
tradition of that was actually handed
down this is the way the early jews
understood it
and it was seen as related to the called
the seat of moses which is that there
was another type of
authority of teaching which was which
was uh
transmitted from moses all the way down
to the pharisees and that the pharisees
were the ones
who held that seat and so it wasn't it
really is
christ saying that the pharisees have
some legitimate
authority in in a jewish thinking jewish
spirituality
uh and then what's funny about that is
he tells people you know you need to
follow what the pharisees say
because they're sitting in the seat of
moses and then right away he goes and
says but don't
do what they do because they're
hypocrites and then he goes on a rant he
goes on a huge rant
where he just is just attacking the
pharisees
for for not embodying the things that
they say
so there are two things one is hypocrisy
in the sense of
let's say going down you could say so
not
embodying the so so saying one thing and
doing another that's one form of
hypocrisy
there's another form of hypocrisy which
is maybe more subtle which christ
criticizes
which is kind of going the other way
around which is
the the incapacity the pharisees have
to see the hidden aspect of the law that
is they
attach themselves to the letter they can
see the rule
but they don't see how that rule
connects to heaven
and is actually manifesting a spiritual
principle
so then he criticizes how you know you
you you follow these little rules but
you don't understand the spiritual
principle
of what it that even those rules are
trying to manifest in the world
and so it's a different it's a more it's
more of a
it's a it's a different kind of
hypocrisy but it's also once again
the problem of how the pharisees were
incapable of
of or were unwilling to connect heaven
incapable and unwilling
to connect the spiritual element and the
physical element um
in those two ways and so then
the other way that christ criticizes the
powerful
is the question of being rich and so
this is something which you'll see
coming later in the christian tradition
you'll see some
people like saint john chrysostom who
says that christ basically revealed
the reason for which there are rich
people and poor people
that christ revealed the reason for
which they are powerful people
and that they're that they are are are
weak people
is so that those above care for those
below
and that the reason for the rich is so
that they care for the poor
that is the spiritual reason for why
rich people exist
and so when they don't do that then they
are actually perturbing the very
structure of reality they're preventing
reality from
from functioning properly they're
preventing the waters
from above to descend down into the
world
and and feed the world and so when the
rich
hold their belongings to themselves and
then don't
send them down the hierarchy so that
everything gets
filled up with this with with the riches
then they are preventing the world from
functioning properly
from connecting that which is above and
that which is below
you can see it of course in the story of
the rich man and lazarus
where you have a rich man who sees
a problem and so you can understand the
poor in in very much in a kind of
feminine way
in which the poor presents a problem
presents a need
presents uh uh you know an emptiness
let's say and the purpose of that which
is above
is to answer the question is to solve
the problem and it's to fill
the emptiness with presence and so
when the rich doesn't care for the poor
that's they're not doing that in the
sphere of reality in which they
participate and so you you see the rich
man walking out of his house he sees the
poor man
on the ground you know with nothing with
no food
begging and there but he ignores it he
ignores the question that is being posed
him
and he refuses to answer it he refuses
to
answer the prayer you could say and so
he and so god
answers the prayers god god sends from
above like christ says that god will
take care of your basic needs
that that just like you know just when
christ talks about the birds and the
the birds and the flowers in the fields
that that god does
send down the blessing so that those
that are below
receive from above and are able to be
filled with what would come from above
and so when the the high person
the authority or the or the rich doesn't
do that then they are they're they
are refusing to act fractally
you know as an image of god in the world
because that's their
that's their uh that's their role as
powerful people
is to represent let's say that which is
above towards that which is below at a
smaller level
and so their responsibility is to give
and to care and yes also
especially in terms of political
authorities they're also there to
discipline and also there to let's say
make sure that things
work right uh but they but that one's
usually a lot easier right it's a lot
easier to clamp down your authority
on those that are below and make them
wake make them
uh do the things you want but you also
that has to be done
in a spirit of of attending to the needs
of those that are below so you can
imagine that
it's it really is like those that are
above are
fractally like fathers towards children
and those
those that manifest themselves as below
them in in whatever capacity that is
it's their responsibility to care for
them to make sure that their needs are
met to make sure
that they are also able to
kind of come into a body and be a
healthy body that manifests this this
kind of pattern of heaven
um and so in the teachings of christ in
christianity
like there is no room for revolution
there is also no room for like less fair
capitalism i'm sorry to tell you guys
there's no room for the idea that it's
not
the rich person's responsibility to care
for their workers that it's not the rich
it's not the boss's responsibility to
try to make sure that
the that he can let's say that he can
fill the needs of the people that he
works for uh
you know this kind of a capitalist idea
that if something's not profitable you
just fire a bunch of people and you
don't
think about it you know that is also not
the christian way of seeing because
the idea of making a lot of money is not
the first reason for the rel the
the let's say the relationship between
the rich and the poor
and so there is a way in which no matter
how it happens
like whether you know no matter whether
it happens
privately or through through through
public means
there is a way in which the
responsibility of any christian
nation or any christian group to care
for the poor to send down that which
they have
so that so that they can it's actually a
blessing to do that
and so doing that actually is something
which is making you in the image of god
in that moment
uh and so and and so and of course there
is
nonetheless a way in which we are all
poor and then that's also why christ
really emphasizes the image of poverty
because let's say
in comparison to god we are all like the
poor
and so we can also meditate and seeing
the way that the poor
are the way that the poor need the way
that the poor
have nothing and receive need to receive
from above then we we can see that
there's a mystery in there
which is that we are all like that that
we all should be like that
that we should all all give away our
pride
and stop thinking that we've got it
covered stop thinking that we are the
ones
that we are self-originated and that we
are responsible for our successes
and realize that even as people that are
more fortunate that all that we have we
receive from above
so we also always need to keep the
attitude
of the poor in relationship to god and
to them
to the extent that then we are fortunate
to the extent in which we are
rich not necessarily just in money but
in skill but in
in authority in capacity all these
things that we have the talents
that that god gives us we need to then
be able to make them
fruitful and one of the ways to make
them fruitful is to let's say
make them flow down the hierarchy make
others participate
in that which you have whether if you're
if you if you're a businessman
you know by employing people is also
where you can do that but making sure
in your the way that you treat your
employees in the way that you consider
your employees
that you're doing it in a manner that
reflects the love of god
for others and you can't as a christian
see people as just numbers and just a
bunch of numbers on a ledger
that you can cut or remove or you know
do whatever just because
just because it's not financially
feasible for you to act one way or the
other
and so so i think that there are some
people i mean i guess because people
can't think out of the box in in uh in
the good way
that is that they think that just
because i'm telling you christianity is
not revolutionary
that's that i'm somehow uh like a
right-wing laissez-faire capitalist i'm
not i don't believe that
you know i'm not saying that i have
political solutions to how
it is that that the poor need to be
uh taken care of but that is definitely
a responsibility that
that christians have and that they need
to
constantly be aware of and especially
for us in
the west in which we are very powerful
and we have
much riches then we specifically need to
look for opportunities
to give to the poor and to help those
around us that appear to us
as lacking or struggling or
are not having enough and being in in a
position of need
we need to make a specific attention uh
to do that
uh you know not just for some moral
reason not just because if you don't
you're a bad person but really because
if when you do that you are actually
participating in the way that god acts
in the world you are being
the image of god uh in the world when
you when you do that so it's actually an
opportunity to do that
to be a generous a person and to give is
an opportunity to really participate
in uh in the life of god um and so but
it is
you know and but but the criticism that
christ has of the rich
is is accurate because
it's very difficult right it's very
difficult when you have a lot to
to to make that flow down it's very
difficult to not want to think
that it's owed to your own skill and to
your own uh
to your own success and want to hold
that for yourself i mean it's
it's nearly impossible and so the way
that
but those that succeed in that they also
participate
in uh in the kingdom of god and they
participate in
in the life of god and so this is my
little
my commentary on that hopefully it's a
it's a good
balance to my last video about how
christianity isn't revolutionary
i really do believe that christianity
shows the
the uh the proper way in which any type
of hierarchy
should exist because they end up being
inevitable and so
so i think that that's the best way to
understand it and
and even in terms of political
revolutions i've often said
and i do think that although there is
i cannot justify let's say the peasants
for killing the king
uh i can understand you know if the king
doesn't care for his people
you know i'm not saying that killing the
king is is morally right or that it's
it's good but i also i don't make the
king innocent of what happened
you know it's like it
it's one of those situations where
scandal must happen you know woe
to those by whom it happens but
sometimes it's gonna happen especially
if
if the the relationship between heaven
and earth isn't the proper one
that at some point the earth grumbles
you see that in scripture
you know you see the israelites grumble
in the desert all the time because
they're not getting what they want
uh and then but it's funny because they
grumble and then god gives them what
they want so there's
there's this this interesting
relationship of
god being annoyed that of of the
grumbling of the people
uh but then nonetheless answering their
grumbles
uh anyway so that's an interesting
aspect as well to understand
uh to understand sometimes how that
happens in practice
you know and how the lady that annoyed
the judge right you have this image in
uh in scripture of the lady that
that was pestering the judge um
and that somehow sometimes that is how
we need to act towards god and that's
how we
we that's also how the problems of the
world kind of manifest themselves to you
as this pestering
uh that you need to answer but it is our
responsibility to
to answer properly in love to those to
those needs to those
emptinesses that we can perceive in the
world and so thanks to everybody for
attention thank you for
your support i know that for some of you
this has been a strange month in terms
of my website and in terms of uh
participating because you're not able to
log in and so i'm i hope that it
is been fixed and i hope that it's
continuing to be fixed one person said
that
in order if you can't log into the
website one of the things you should do
is that you should that you should
accept the cookie so if the website asks
you to accept the cookies
then then it will help you to log in and
so i don't know anything
what that totally entails in terms of
technical stuff but uh hopefully that
works for you so i thank you for support
sorry for the chaos and i'll talk to you
very soon bye-bye